[Music]
I'm Evan Anderson I'm a software
engineer at Google working on Google's
server list product but this talk is
going to be half serverless and half
conversational interactions with Google
and this is a 300 level talk so in the
second half you'll get to see a bit of
the development process and tools for
actually building some of the demos and
stuff that you'll see earlier and as you
can see the title is okay Google asked
service Google home I didn't ask for you
yet okay I think we I think you may be
in the corner and we'll be using our
phones this talk is called okay Google
asked service to sell my product and
we'll be talking about building
conversational interfaces for Google
assistant and I don't know how many of
you have been using this already in the
conference if you want to queue up
questions in the Dory Q&A I will check
them at the end if you want to just use
the live mics we have a couple of live
mics and those will work just as well so
it's there you can use it you can see in
the app where to find it to put in the
questions and vote for stuff so far no
one had questions so feel free to just
go to the mics if you prefer and to
start with we're going to lay out the
basic architecture which as you can see
you get one of these little Google
devices one like this or one that's a
little harder to throw and then that
talks to the Google assistant in the
cloud and is able to fulfill all of your
conversational requests using google's
AI and back-end fulfillment you can
integrate directly with the Google
assistant but it's a lot easier if you
use a service like dialog flow that
already has built in natural language
processing tools so it can understand
voice and text and
then all you need to do is handle the
recognize text and the conversational
pieces that are specific to your
application that works for both the
voice interfaces and for a text
interface on your phone which you may
have used before and there's a
third-party plugin for you know from
dialogue flow to call cloud functions or
your own web hook on Prem or wherever it
makes the most sense and now I'd like to
invite John kniffen of discount tire up
onstage to talk about the conversational
experience that they're building at
discount tire thanks Evan I'm John with
discount tire if you're one of our
customers here in Northern California
you might know us as America's tire same
company same experience so I work with a
group that focuses on customer
experience and delivering new things to
to help that out we have a problem
statement there you can read we want to
make sure we're delivering a consistent
experience that help meets our customers
future needs one of the big items that
we focus on here is taking some of our
unplanned purchase customers and turning
them into planned purchase customers so
I'm sure some of you have gone to to a
shop or a tire store for service right
of your regular maintenance and then the
dreaded guy comes up out of the back and
says oh by the way you need you know new
windshield wipers and blinker fluid and
all of the other things and it's going
to cost you half a mortgage payment and
you weren't planning on it same thing
can happen with us
people customers will come in for the
regular maintenance and then we tell the
story based on different conditions that
you need new tires when they weren't
expecting it one of the gaps here is the
way we stay in touch with our customers
and allow them to stay in touch with us
so we want to make sure we close as many
gaps as we can including this one so
we've we've got some things you can see
some of the screen shots there we've
we've got some tie recommendation tools
they were rolling out to make it easier
to pick the right tire know which one is
gonna fit your needs the best but we
want to make sure that customers can
contact us the way they want one of
those methods
is gonna be through conversation via
voice or chat or any of the new things
that come along
so we'll demo a little later and show
you where we've started with
conversation and just scheduling an
appointment but the vision is to move
forward and move beyond that to be able
to recommend products services anything
additional via any Avenue including
voice and chat that the customer wants
to do business with us and that just
helps helps ease some of that buying
tires is not fun we know that none of
you enjoy it it's okay we try and make
it as painless as we possibly can so now
Becky is gonna come up and talk a little
bit about what we've done so far thanks
John
I'm Becky shoe with Capgemini consulting
for those of you who haven't heard of us
in the past
Capgemini consulting is a global
consulting firm we partner with
companies like Google we also have an
Innovation Lab we partner with MIT as
well as the University of Chicago so
that we can be on the forefront of
what's going on with trends within
technology we work with our clients to
make sure that we can solve business
problems and strategies through the use
of IT so I'm here to talk to you about
conversational commerce I'm not the 300
level course part of this this is more
what's your application where did it
come from so if we look at
conversational Commerce in general it
has been adapted faster than any other
technology that has been known to date
so faster than the tablet 286 percent a
year of a year is what the adaption rate
was for cell phones but as you can see
on here conversational Commerce has been
adapted at 653 percent year-over-year in
the last five years so just out of
curiosity by show hands how many of you
currently have some kind of a smart
speaker device in your in your home okay
and hold your hands up a lil bit longer
sorry I know exercise day how long how
many of you have had
for longer than a year leave your hands
up and if you've had it longer than two
years longer than three years like one
or two people so you can see how quickly
has been adapted just in the last few
years as you can see here
statistics show that we have a hundred
and twenty million smart speakers in
people's homes in the US alone which is
pretty amazing because there are a
hundred and twenty seven million
households so if you if you think about
that that's that's a lot of devices
which doesn't mean that we should go out
and get into the smart speaker device
business but it's really the utilization
of those so if we look at how trends
have gone in the last few years and we
go back a little bit it's hard to fathom
sometimes just where it's going where is
conversational commerce going you hear a
lot of people say well I've got my
Google home and it does my kids homework
or it tells me the news in the morning
it plays music but really it's not gonna
do anything more for me however if we
think about the way trends have gone in
the past just by a quick scan of our
group here today most of you probably
have never had a television in your home
without a remote control you couldn't
really think about getting up off the
couch right now and changing that
channel and that's exactly what people
said when remote controls first came out
why would I have to have this thing when
I can just get up and change enough well
most of us would never even think about
turning a knob anymore in fact most of
us or a lot of us now use the little
microphone on our remote control so you
can see how things suddenly become
adapted and part of our life same thing
with cell phones when cell phones first
came out we had a PDA of Palm Pilot
which kept all of our contacts and our
pictures and people said you know I
can't imagine having a phone and my
contacts and calendar device in one
thing and I have to talk then I have to
look but I have to talk it seems
ridiculous well now I don't think any of
us would really consider having two
separate devices for something like that
same holds true for conversational
commerce in people's homes
you're seeing more and more people take
their google home device or other device
and connect it to their lights to their
furnace systems their a/c systems their
garage doors what have you so it's
starting to move forward that way as a
result what we're seeing as our clients
are really trying to capture that and
and work with their clients so that they
can get to know who their end clients
are this is important because as you can
see people are starting to order things
from their devices the other thing
that's interesting is that devices that
have been developed have sort of a
personality if you will based on how
they were developed to begin with the
google home device you know google
itself was developed on a platform that
was a search engine so what you see is
that there's a lot that you can leverage
when you're developing on a Google home
platform there is a wealth of data out
there location services etc as well as
the API is that you can leverage from
Google which make it very easy to then
bring this into people's homes what
we're seeing in terms of trends is that
not only are people starting to develop
and adapt to digital and conversational
commerce but what we're seeing is that
eventually we'll have what we call a
digital twin that digital device will
know you so well it will know your your
moods your birthdays your kids birthdays
and it will soon replace what used to be
sort of a shopkeeper down the street
how long ago a shopkeeper down the
street knew you by name they knew when
you came in to buy you know your bread
your wine whatever it was if you had a
bad day they knew if you celebrated
Hannukah Diwali or Christmas or whatever
it was that you celebrated so that then
they would prepare their products
accordingly same holds true with
conversational commerce what we're
seeing is that it's becoming a part of
people's lives so much that it will
eventually develop a digital twin for
you so that it will automatically
take care of things for you that you you
may not have expected it to in the past
so that's what we're seeing from a
personal perspective what we're seeing
from an industry perspective is that
companies are going to start shifting
not just to providing services and
information to their consumer on the
front end but leveraging conversational
commerce on the back end so that they
can reduce costs in supply chain
manufacturing training and things like
that in conjunction with the AI and IOT
that they can couple with that so these
are some of the trends that we're seeing
going forward as I mentioned and what
Jon will show you in just a moment is
that we partner with our clients to
solve for various solutions that they're
looking for in this case we've developed
an application which just a heads up
this is in our beta so it's in one store
so if those of you are discontent tire
customers we're first rolling it out to
the Arizona store so that we can make
sure that the is trained because most of
you know you have to train that bots so
that it becomes proficient in various
types of call-outs and sequences because
we're leveraging Google's back-end we
were able to then leverage the location
services the maps the AP api's or you
know the api's that exists and pull that
in from discount Tires api's and also
then connect it to their appointment and
calendaring system that exists in their
store so what you'll see is that we're
able to then make that call out in the
the Google device that goes through the
cloud of course connects through into
the Gateway via the API gateway into
discount Tires store and then it sets
the appointment not only in your Google
Calendar but also at the store so I'm
going to ask John to come up here and
show that to you
and want to thank you for your time
alright we had we had a fight with the
speaker so we're gonna do the demo on my
phone
hopefully everybody can hear it okay
talk to discount tire okay
getting discount tire hi there to get to
know you better I'll just need to get
your name email address and current
location from Google is that okay sure
hi John
welcome to discount tire right now this
test version only works for the
Scottsdale area and you seem to be
located in San Francisco California USA
would you like to continue yes we are
currently test driving this only at our
Scottsdale location at the corner of
Shea and North Scottsdale would you like
to schedule an appointment at this
location yep
what do you need an appointment for you
can also ask me to list services offered
new tires okay do you want to get new
tires is that right yeah we have
openings on Thursday the 11th of April
Friday the 12th of April and Saturday
the 13th of April which day would you
like to come in Saturday would you like
your appointment for the morning early
afternoon or late afternoon morning for
the morning of the 13th of April we are
available at 8:30 a.m. 9 a.m. and 9:30
a.m. tell me which one of those will
work for you or you can ask me for more
available times 9 do you want me to
confirm your appointment for the 13th of
April at 9:00 a.m. yes great we have you
scheduled at 9:00 a.m. on the 13th of
April for new tires wheels consultation
appointment at 7075 East Shea Boulevard
in Scottsdale
the corner of chez and North Scottsdale
Road an appointment confirmation has
been sent to your email address see you
soon so pretty basic and simple but it's
a good way to start and that's nice
about working with Google and partners
like Capgemini is is that we can do some
of these small things to build momentum
and she said it was in beta so you can't
get it it's it's actually in production
so I did create an appointment for that
store just now I'm gonna have to call
the manager and tell him not to get
excited about the new tires he's not
gonna sell but he can take care of that
part and so that was it Evan Thanks
that was a great overview of both
conversational commerce and where that's
going as well as some of the business
value and how it's really going into
production and as well as Becky had a
great slide about how to integrate these
sorts of experiences into your existing
infrastructure because how many people
are building their new enterprise stuff
completely Greenfield without needing to
integrate with any existing databases I
see one hand in the back congratulations
you are the lucky one but otherwise
building this as a facade in front with
clear enterprise api's is a great way to
get into into this and experiment and
move quickly without destabilizing the
rest of your infrastructure so I'm a
software engineer as I said at the
beginning I like to see how stuff is
built and so we're going to start
talking about how it's built and a
little bit about why I why I think the
server list is the great place to do
this so at the end I will point you to
the github repo where you can go and
take a look and you know copy the code
and look at all the stuff I did and ask
me questions about you know why why is
your Python code so hastily written in
the
is its demo so to review the request
flow this is very similar to before you
know I talked to Google on my device it
calls the assistant the assistant calls
dialog flow because this is not about
training your own natural language model
there's lots of people who've done this
before and Google has a pretty good
agent and then at the end I want to hook
this up with some Python code because
it's fast and easy to write I don't have
to spend a lot of time on it and it's
kind of fun to get to see how far Python
has gone since I wrote it seriously in
production five or ten years ago so this
is a Google conference we've got lots of
places where you can run Python also
lots of places where you can answer this
stuff that's not Google so all the way
on the left you've got on-premise maybe
you've got an existing VM all you need
to do is set that up image the disk talk
to your IT department about firewalls
and network access so Google can call it
doesn't sound quite so much fun so
Google compute engine if you like having
VMs and you know just pop out a credit
card and you can get a VM and when
you're done with it just throw it away
you still have to handle a lot of
scaling and replication yourself and
still need to deal with OSS and patches
well it's a little bit more agile a
little bit less infrastructure work
because you can just show up one day and
you don't have to like procure interface
plan but let's keep going up the stack
two more managed solutions kubernetes
engine is next in kubernetes engine
Google manages the OS and a lot of the
other components and you simply tell
kubernetes hey this is the container I
want to run please run five copies put a
load balancer in front if you've ever
used kubernetes before you can declare
all of this stuff in a gamal format
you'll spend a lot of time making
friends with llamó
and you'll get to see how all the pieces
fit together which is great if you like
fitting pieces together we're still
focused on okay
I just want to get my code to run so
you'll see that we have the three
compute service offerings up here cloud
functions is great for single HTTP
endpoint requests we're you're only
going to get one request at a time
App Engine is a full web application
environment so you know for Python I'm
going to use flask for node you could
use Express you're going down a very
well-trod path there but if you want to
just handle a single JSON request
there's going to be a little bit more
overhead those first two are G a if
you're building something for production
today use the GA ones the last one is
new something we're announcing at this
conference cloud run it is a container
based service environment so you can
take a container that runs on your
desktop
send it up into the cloud and Google
will scale it Google will give us SL
that's the cell on all three by the way
that's not a cloud run exclusive feature
but you can use any language you want
the first two are language specific so
there are four languages I think
supported for cloud functions about six
languages and two or three versions of
each language on App Engine but if you I
see my comic here if you want to write
it an elixir then you're gonna build
your own container and do the last thing
if you want to do rust or something like
that again the last one and I don't want
to point out if you've got simple needs
dialog flow actually is a managed
service where you can do all of your
programming and dialogue flow as long as
you don't need to do something
complicated like access that database so
we can't use the fully managed product
because we've got a database that we
want to do
we've got existing enterprise things and
we already talked about why you want to
go as far up the management stack as
possible so server list is a great place
to do these sorts of simple web hooks
I'm actually going to use both cloud
functions and App Engine in this talk
because I wanted to use the GA products
and show you
what I would recommend for for building
things today with cloud run I could have
put this all in a single container which
has some nice advantages in terms of
managing modules and things like that
so serverless other people have said
this it's like a high-level language for
cloud if you some of you have probably
you know been from basic or see up to
object-oriented languages where you can
get a lot of encapsulation and remove a
lot of duplication from your code and
server list is the same sort of thing
you get a lot of stuff for free you get
scaling and paper use and that includes
scale down to zero so when you're not
using it you pay nothing which is great
for development environments because
probably I could I if I were paying for
this rather than having Google pay for
it it would have cost me somewhere
between free and 25 cents to do all the
development work in terms of serving
obviously my hours are more than that
you also get a lot of stuff for free
like SSL I mentioned earlier in network
routing so App Engine allows you to roll
out versions incrementally that
functionality is coming for cloud run
and there's some similar things you can
do with functions
it steers you towards a bunch of best
practices that your IT department will
love stateless applications are way
easier to handle you have a problem you
can roll back to the previous version
it's super fast it will almost always
solve your issue if the application was
at fault you don't have to worry about
Oh what about customers who are on the
new version you could just move them
back similarly we take care of OS
patches access control tools and things
like that a bunch of other problems that
you probably prefer not to have and
basically it's just your code all the
time now there are some cases not so
much for dialogue flow because dialogue
flow is very carefully designed to let
you be a stateless web app but if you
are interrelated with actions
Google or you were building some other
types of things if you're keeping local
storage like a session cache or
something like that serverless
is not the place to go you need to put
that in an external service because all
of a sudden you have five instances and
sessions are bouncing between them and
people are forgetting that they're
logged in and everybody said and your
individual instances aren't addressable
so if you're thinking thinking of doing
something fancy and complicated you
don't know how many instances you're
gonna have and you can't control where
the requests go so in this particular
demo I have the assistant hooked up to
dialog flow and then using cloud
functions to service that web hook
because it's a single request I also
have a management interface that's on
App Engine that's multiple pages is a
little web application where you can see
all of your orders and on a different
page where the chefs can see what they
need to make because I'm making a
application for ordering food because
goodness knows there's not enough ways
to order food yet and in the backend
everything is being stored in cloud fire
store which has a interesting
functionality where if you're in fire
store mode you can set a trigger on
certain objects that will call a cloud
function every time they change and so
every time the order changes I have a
chance to view it and decide is it time
to send it off to external payment
processing is there other work like you
know going back and recomputing the
total price of the order that I should
do because look it just changed and it's
a cute way this pattern with triggers
and then going back to the same data
data store or fire store is a cute way
of building a little state machine where
you don't need to separately use
something like pub/sub and your database
and think carefully about how to manage
the transactions between the two and so
all of these components including the
database actually our server lists
because fire store will scale up to
thousands of requests per second if you
need it
again if you're storing very little or
no data it cost you nothing because it's
in the free tier you pay only for what
you use and so this is where I'm going
to switch over and show you just show
you this simulator for actions on Google
so this is the way that you would
actually go to develop your application
when you're in test mode it has a nice
user interface you can also link it to
your phone you can see up here that
there is an option for testing on device
and I have it enabled so I can also try
testing thing with a phone it's a little
faster for testing to just be able to
type here and it has nice suggestions so
I can say you know talk to the demo shop
and it should give back to me after a
moment the other great thing is that you
can see for debugging all of the
requests that are getting sent and the
responses that are coming back so you
can see my code said it's a great day
for a demo so let's see what's on the
menu and we have three items this is
this is being pulled dynamically from
the database again I didn't really want
to spend a lot of time coming up with
cute data so you can see that we have
three dishes and it's just fetching
these let me make that bigger for you
and so it's going through these three
dishes and then you can say I'd like to
start an order and it will go and
actually you can see up here that I have
sandbox transactions and if this was the
first time I was using it I would have
to actually allow the app to access my
payment information and that actually
has to be done on a device not on the
simulator so you know there's a couple
things that you can't do here you can't
actually place a payment through the
simulator but it's really helpful for
debugging everything but the last stage
so can we switch back to the slides now
okay so a little bit about how I've laid
out data in firestore if you haven't
used it firestore is a document database
so it holds collections of documents
under different names and an individual
document can have further you know can
have further collections under it so you
can see under salads we have a bunch of
different choices like what greens do
you want and do you want avocado for an
extra charge and we have a separate
collection that is orders and then
inside each order there's you know a
dishes a list of you know what type it
is and then what items you've chosen to
include and the total price and then
there's a whole collection of orders and
we have cloud functions set up to listen
on those orders which is actually kind
of fun when you're using the development
viewer because you can change values and
you can see the live updates as your
background function comes in and you
know fixes things or adjust them and
when I was writing code and I discovered
I had bad values for some of the
computed stuff I could just go in and
delete it that caused the function to
re-evaluate it and create
to create the correct data in terms of
dialogue flow can you can we switch back
to the demo machine I'm going to give
you a lot of practice switching back and
forth so those of you who haven't used
it before the ID dialogue flow has a
bunch of so this is the show me a menu
and you enter a variety of training
phrases and let's look at a more
interesting item now so the ad intent
lets you say hey I want to get a salad
or something like that
and you give it a list of these entities
that it might fill in so salads and
bowls and whatever I was feeling healthy
when I got started are all filled in and
you give it several different training
phrases that it can learn where those
foods might be so this is great if you
like having a UI to keep track of all
this stuff but for a more production
environment you may want to instead
export this as a zip file so if you go
over here to export you can export this
as a zip file and then import it and you
can see here that here are the different
things that the user might say you know
I want a salad it's a dish it's the dish
entity and it's defined by a user hey
can I get a another thing so having the
UI is nice for creating these to begin
with but if but you can then actually
download this and check it into source
control and then create a zip file and
restore it to load things back up so if
you're doing development one place doing
a production elsewhere this is a great
a great tool for seeing what's going on
can we go back to the slides I'm gonna
give you folks a workout on the video so
there's various different items that the
web book can return with so one thing
that they can do is just hey here's some
more text you can also say something
like hey I want this person to start a
transaction or complete a transaction so
starting a transaction says please make
sure that they've got all their payment
information they're willing to share it
with you completing the transaction
gives them actually this is what your
total price is going to be do you want
to you know do you want to pay it or not
and you can also set context information
that will be carried along to the future
so when you say I'd like to place an
order we actually the demo creates an
order in fire store and then puts that
into dialogue flow so that the next time
you make a request
the next webhook knows what that is and
let's see yes so this is what the
webhook looks like so you get a single
request and it tells you which of those
different intents it is and each of
those is basically a separate function
so in node there's a nice wrapper that
lets you map these you know just
annotate these names being different
functions in Python it's really easy to
write a little wrapper that does the
same thing so that's what we have here
is just a quick dispatch loop and you
know whatever you want to add a new
function you write the function and then
just add it to handlers along with the
mapping to those dialogue flow and for
local development and testing you can
use flask and in grok and get a much
faster development cycle and get
interactive debugging when you're
getting things up setup so and rock is
one of several services that will run a
endpoint on the web and then proxy it to
your local machine if you're behind a
firewall so
that was how I did a lot of the initial
iteration I'll also show you how I do it
with cloud functions cloud functions
takes a little while mmm 30 seconds or
so most of the time for this for this
Python app so it's a little bit slower
but not terribly slow but it's sometimes
nice to have that instantaneous loop and
can we switch back to the demo machine
and I will show what this code looks
like and maybe we will see about let's
see in main let's see we can let's see
that's still a builder so where we say
we have so and so many you know items on
the menu we can instead change this to
it's a surprise and comment these others
out so we don't have to ask as often and
the deploy command looks something like
this down at the bottom deploy the voice
function triggered by HTTP it's the
Python 37 runtime so that's pretty much
the latest version of Python and it'll
take a moment or two to upload and you
can go over and this is still working
after about 20 minutes it will timeout
your interaction so we will get started
again and there's some built-in chitchat
that google ships with that gives you a
few suggestions for stuff that you can
leave on or not there's one that's like
tell me a joke that you might ever tell
us so this is still building it says it
might take up to two minutes the other
thing that you can do while this is
going on is you can look at the existing
logs and you can see we just we just
made this request this is the Welcome
intent this is all logging that I added
and you know here we're responding with
some text that says it's a great day for
a demo and now it looks like we have
updated the function so let's see what's
on the menu
it's a surprise so it took a moment but
so that's the that's sort of the
iteration cycle when you're working in
the cloud obviously you can still work
pretty fast but if you have flasks
reloading on local changes it's you know
it's almost instant although it can be
hard to read the logs I actually found
that find the log viewer to be easier to
pick things out then when you just get a
whole bunch of output and so this is
yeah and we were checking the user as
well because at one point we said hello
to the person so I could also you'll see
here there's a little bit of integration
with Google identity so you can get the
users name and so forth if they've given
you that permission I set this up
already so it's there can you switch me
back to the slides please let's see so
we already talked about most of this in
a minute I will probably walk through
this back-end processing piece but this
is basically what it looks like that
validate method is where you put all
your business logic for you know oh hey
is the price right you know we should
update it you know extract all the
fields and so forth the important thing
to note is this last block at the bottom
that says you know if these two
documents are different then set them
otherwise don't if you don't do that
differencing part at the end and you
just always do an unconditional Set
ughhhhh it's serverless it will scale
and you have created an infinite loop
so we can scale that pretty fast your
bill scales with usage so you may want
to you know if you're doing this pattern
of writing back to the same document you
may want to put in a few safety checks
that you're not going to you know
overwhelm the database in a spin loop
so in my particular case it made more
sense to treat this as let's check a
condition let's fix that condition check
the condition and fix the condition but
you could also have a field that was a
state machine so you know order received
we've you know created your appointment
we've sent a follow-up email to ask you
you know what kind of car do you have
we've sent you a suggestion of tires
we've got the tires ordered and you know
now everything's ready to go and then
the last piece is a status web
application so it's great being able to
place orders through you know a chat
interface maybe you're in the car or
something like that we only want to be
able to see hey what are all the last
orders that I had and so voice isn't
going to replace those sorts of
interfaces it's going to add to them and
some things will make more sense to do
in a web UI so if you can flip back to
the demo machine again you can see my
beautiful web design skills and this is
a history of all of the orders that
you've completed and to show how a
little bit of this reconciliation loop
works if we go over and look at the
orders I done this with a couple
different so this is the this is that
last order in the list and if I decide
to change the value I can do that and
over here it will tell me I paid not I
they're two of the
well so my web skills are apparently
really bad forestry load it has cash 15
dollars and I apparently don't know how
to do cash busting I'm a back-end
engineer so this was all fun for me but
the fun thing that you can do here is if
you delete the price for example you
will see it pop back up in just a moment
add it again that's that back here
background processing process
recognizing hey there's not a total on
here I should go compute it and the
actual code looks pretty simple if we
don't have a total just update it if
it's not done and we got a payment token
from stripe this has asleep because I
didn't finish integrating with stripes
stripes API but up the other pattern for
this is if you have some data you don't
want to check in you can have a config
and this cuts off the right-hand side
intentionally because I don't want you
to see my full keys but I can store some
keys in here and then load them on every
application request without needing to
like write that down in a config file
that gets checked in to get instead I
project them on the screen for everybody
but they're cut off as I said but yes
this here's a here's an object in your
database that stores all your config is
really handy for development development
versus production environments and you
know fire store is a really good place
for this because it lets you have just
sort of amorphous objects where you can
add another key if you need to so if I
discovered you know I needed
an extra key it can be a string or I can
even you know like have a JavaScript map
and nest things yeah so if you can
switch them back to the slides I put a
debugging view on that's basically a
view for the chef it looks a lot like
that other page except that it has all
the items in a little bit more detail
like which ingredients you should have
and you get also get a lot of these
debugging tools so you saw the log
viewer stackdriver also has a trace
mechanism so you can see why is my app
slow and you know frequency latency
there's also request tracing through the
system so you can say you know oh hey I
called firestore you know eight times it
turns out and that's why everything is
slow is because I should really
consolidate that down to two database
calls and server list gives you a lot of
these batteries included so there's only
a small amount of work to integrate
whereas if you're running on a VM you
might have a much larger list of get the
monitoring agent installed figure out
what credentials it needs figure out
which monitoring agent you're going to
use and so server list has picked a lot
of this stuff for you and so this is a
bunch of information but before we get
to the QA would love to get your
feedback on this session you can
complete the session survey in your app
and you know leave notes I get to see at
least the summary information and any of
those comments so you know if we did
something particularly great or if you
wish this session was about something
completely different that's your place
to let me know
[Music]